onze tableaux
etc et leur
souplesse et de lutter tous à vos petro
devrait devenir le prochain président de
la colombie du moins s'il n'est pas
assassiné dans un pays qui a une longue
tradition de meurtres de candidats
présidentiels
il a dû annuler des déplacements à cause
de menaces de groupes
narcoparamilitaires que tout le monde a
pris au sérieux aussi cet ancien député
sénateur maire de bogota a toutes les
chances de gagner sauf si les partisans
du gouvernement sortant parviennent à
reporter voire à annuler l'élection ça
c'est de ce manoir c'est ce sénateur
rodrigo lara qui a sonné l'alarmé les
conservateurs du président du quai
sentent la défaite son gouvernement est
trop impopulaire la plupart des
colombiens vivent dans l'informalité ils
n'ont pas dépensé un sou dans cette
population ce qu'elle fait le show cat
est très brutal est en pleine crise
d'une qu'ovide mal géré le président
ivan bouquet lance une réforme fiscale
avec une tva sur les produits
alimentaires ces produits alimentaires
qui sont très sensibles dans une
population très pauvre ou d'informalité
pas fait que le
a provoqué une explosion une crise
sociale d'une dimension que nous
n'avions pas vécu depuis 1948 et ce qui
a été accompagné bien sûr tout de suite
par le surgissement des démons de notre
société
[Applaudissements]
federico gutiérrez surnommé fico tente
de se distancer du gouvernement sortant
cet ancien maire de medellin veut lutter
contre l'insécurité et la pauvreté
il ya 20 millions de colombiens en
situation de pauvreté presque 40 % de la
population
ingrid betancourt la franco-colombienne
ex-otage des farc décidément très
impopulaire en colombie a renoncé à sa
candidature pour soutenir rodolfo
fernandez ce milliardaire populiste
pourrait jouer le trouble fête pour les
deux candidats en tête ils veulent la
paix la réconciliation et la fondation
d'un nouveau pays - oh pas ici combien
sa carrière solo à celle connue hier ou
ce pays dit elle nous allons faire
ensemble la paix a été fait avec la
guérilla des farc il y a 6 ans mais elle
ne règne pas les problèmes de base reste
reste donc vous avez des zones entières
du pays sans état vous avez des
véritables archipel humains qui sont un
peu ce même un peu partout dans le pays
qui n'ont pas d'accès aux services
essentiels de l'état ces zones sont
encore et toujours sous l'emprise des
groupes armés
ex farc e hélène par un militaire narco
du clan du golfe qui terrorise encore
des régions entières ces régions vont
voter pour le candidat de gauche gustavo
petro des violences permanentes est ce
de manière infinie
terminale il faut mettre un terme aux
violences permanentes et une guerre sans
fin où des générations ont répandu leur
sang
reste à savoir à quel point les grandes
villes du pays pour le même désir de
paix l'élection d'un président de gauche
en colombie serait une première dans
l'histoire du pays au premier tour plus
probablement au second le 19 juin mais
il reste beaucoup d'inconnues des
sondages peu fiable et aussi une
abstention généralement très élevé ici
en colombie peuvent donner lieu à
beaucoup de surprises jean michel
leprince radio canada bogota